Speaker 1: Speaking of Fox News, two, just
pathetic moments from last night that I want
to go over with you. First and foremost. As Trump
was getting ready to speak at Bedminster after
his second arrest yesterday, that is the speech
in which Trump admitted to many of the crimes
he's accused of having committed. Brian KILMEADE
introduces Trump as the president of the United
States. Now, I've been there and I've defended it,
generally speaking, referring to him as President
Donald Trump in the context of once you've been
president, you keep that title. People introduce,
you know, President George W Bush or whatever.
When you have a live event and you say the
president of the United States will now speak,
that is a. Different level all together. Listen
to this insanity.
Speaker 5:
Let's take you the last moments. This is
the president of the United States about to
address a crowd of reporters and also the first
time after being indicted on federal charges.
Speaker 1: Okay. I know you get to keep the title
president for life. But this is a live news event
where a reporter is tell a reporter I use that
term loosely. A guy on the camera is telling the
audience the president of the United States will
now speak. It would be useful to clarify. We're
talking about former President Donald Trump. If
this wasn't humiliating enough for Fox News last
night, Fox News also ended its 8:00 Eastern
hour with the lower third one to be dictator
speaks at the White House after having
his political rival arrested. Referring to
President Joe Biden, the actual president
wannabe dictator speaks at the White House
after having his political rival arrested. Of
course, they have still presented no evidence
whatsoever that Joe Biden has had any even
passing involvement in this prosecution of
Donald Trump and neither the state nor the
federal level. That was Fox News last night.
Is this part of the ratings decline? I don't
know. Or is this part of what's keeping the
ratings where they are? I really don't know what
to tell you. But an insane night on Fox News, as
insane as Trump's day was, Fox News is night. And
I don't expect this stuff to change any time soon.